[Musik]
das sind die bilder die seit heute ist
die um die welt gehen feder des
schreckens bilder von krieg in europa
sirenen heulen zivilisten sterben putins
krieg hält die welt in atem damit
herzlich willkommen zu einem viertel
nach acht spezial ich begrüße bei mir in
der runde heute abend im designierten
generalsekretär der fdp die gießerei in
früheren bundeswirtschaftsminister peter
altmaier bild chefredakteur und tv chef
claus strunz und weltwoche chefredaktor
roger köppel wir möchten heute an diesem
tag keine normale firma acht sendung
machen wir können und wollen nicht über
inflation krone oder gender sternchen
sprechen während sich die menschen in
der ukraine in schockstarre befinden wir
werden heute monothematisch über putins
angriffskrieg berichten und sie die
ganze sendung über live unsere debatten
werden wir jederzeit zu gunsten der
eilmeldung unterbrechen wir wollten
jetzt eigentlich direkt zu unserem jahr
bild viele bauern selber schalten gerade
geht es noch nicht wie beginnen die
diskussion hier aber wir werden die
ganze sendung über zu den reporter
entscheiden die vor ort sind und dass in
paul ronzheimer philippi ad hoc und
peter thiele wir werden immer wieder ins
geschehen reinschalten aber jetzt die
erste frage geht dann an sie herr
altmaier frau annegret kramp karrenbauer
die frühere verteidigungsministerium hat
gesagt der westen habe historisch
versagt wie sehen sie das ja ich glaube
das erst einmal annegret kramp
karrenbauer dies seit 40 jahren kenne
und wir haben sehr gut
zusammengearbeitet sich doch schon was
dabei gedacht haben wird auf der anderen
seite ich wünsche mir dass wir heute
abend vor allen dingen darüber sprechen
was wir tun können um der ukraine zu
helfen da ist gerade ein volk dessen
freiheit mit füßen getreten wird wir
erleben den größten militärischen
konflikt den es in europa seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg gegeben hat und die
nachrichtendienste der westlichen welt
spekulieren wie lange sich die regierung
in kiew noch halten kann und deshalb ich
glaube dass wir heute abend in brüssel
bei der eu bei der nato aber auch in
deutschland alles tun müssen um uns auf
die frage zu konzentrieren wie kommen
wir in den nächsten 2-3 tagen dahin dass
putin seiner wahnsinnige arbeit
einstellt
eigentlich so dass alles was heute
geäußert wird
ströhen totale machtlosigkeit olaf
schulz erklärt putin wird diesen krieg
nicht gewinnen naja also sieht aber eher
so aus als würde er den krieg gewinnen
weil ihm die ukraine bald gehört wir
sagen
wahrscheinlich haben die menschen in der
ukraine nur noch wenige stunden zeit der
bundestag tritt aber erst am sonntag
zusammen um irgendetwas zu beraten das
ist sie doch aus als wär schon wieder
sozusagen die große machtlosigkeit über
die westliche welt kommen und wenn ich
jetzt mal sozusagen konfrontativ sage
sitzt vladimir putin im kreml und sagt
genauso habe ich mir den westen
vorgestellt ich kämpfe ich bin da ich
nehme mir mein recht und die reden reden
reden reden ermittelt wird sich sehr
freuen wenn er heute abend hört er
versteht ja sehr gut deutsch weil genau
das nämlich die erwartung ist dass wir
uns jetzt gegenseitig fertigmachen
übereinander herfallen statt darüber zu
diskutieren wie wir herrn putin
aufhalten und abschreiben dann sagen sie
es doch seine aggressionen auch mal so
ich habe heute mit ein paar ich habe
heute morgen nicht dazu nein ich habe
mich heute morgen dazu geäußert und
gesagt wir müssen erst einmal bereit
sein geschlossenheit zu demonstrieren
ich habe urlaub scholz nicht gewählt ich
habe die ampel nicht gewählt aber das
ist meine regierung und ich unterstütze
meine regierung dabei dass sie gemeinsam
mit joe biden und den usa ihre renate
und der eu dann die notwendigen
maßnahmen ergreift ich könnte zehn
maßnahmen nennen die ich persönlich für
richtig halte aber das ist dann eine
kakophonie ein durcheinander von vielen
vorstellen die es heute übrigens den
ganzen tag auch immer wieder
stattgefunden hat und deshalb meine
erwartung ist dass auch mein
bundeskanzler den ich heute abend hier
nicht kritisieren werde aber dass er
auch das tut was die anderen im
westlichen bündnis für richtig halten es
gibt eine frage die uns heute sehr
umgetrieben hat das ist die frage wie
gehen wir mit dem banken koordinierungs
systems trifft um wenn es so ist dass
die amerikaner mit klare meinung haben
und die meisten anderen europäer dann
müssen wir als deutsche dafür sorgen
dass wir zu einer klaren antwort an
putin kommen aber die verstehe das alles
und das mittel der wahl sind sanktionen
meine these lautet da wird herr putin
aber ganz schön zittern vor angst vor
diesen sanktionen denn die greifen ja
dann vielleicht in drei monaten die
würden sich in sechs monaten aus in
neuen in zwölf bis dahin hat er die
ukraine längst sich einverleiben regiert
dort mit einer militärregierung und wir
sagen dann ja aber jetzt wird nun
langsam die orangen gefallen wie die
frage an herrn drei weitergehen will ich
einmal probieren ob er zu paul die
schalke jetzt hinbekommen bei unser
stellvertretender chefredakteur von bild
per sms seit wochen vor ort und man muss
auch einfach sagen er hat schon gewarnt
als alle anderen oder zu viele andere
wladimir putin einfach nur verharmlost
haben paul ich weiß nicht ob du es
mitbekommen was die diskussion gerade am
tisch ja nachdem leute alle die mit
diesen erschreckenden bildern aufgewacht
sind annalena baerbock hat gesagt die
welt wird nie wieder die selbe sein was
erwartet uns in den nächsten stunden und
wie kann und muss jetzt auch der besten
reagieren
sind schicksalsstunden für die ukraine
wir sind gerade auf dem weg richtung
kiel das ist fast mitternacht 120
minuten nach mitternacht die menschen in
kiew erwarten weitere angriffe ich habe
gerade eben kurz mit vitali klitschko
telefonieren freundin kiewer
bürgermeister denn auf das schlimmste
vorbereitet ist was in den nächsten
stunden und tagen passieren könnte man
erlebt die nervosität hier auch auf der
strecke auf dem weg dorthin wir sind
gerade in einer tankstelle vorbei
gefahren dort gibt es kein benzin mehr
wir selbst haben bei einer anderen
tankstelle nur noch 20 liter bekommen er
wird bereits rationiert weil die
situation so dramatisch ist gleichzeitig
muss man sagen dass wladimir putin in
den vergangenen stunden und tagen in
einer
erdrückten schnellen weise ihr tatsachen
geschaffen hat einen flughafen umziehen
ein kleiner flughafen ist deutschland
erobert worden tschernobyl
reaktors erobert und wieder leben dass
das ganze hier weitergeht in einer
explosiven mischung
das
kann man als reporter das zu erleben
wenn man so lange diesen konflikt auch
über den berichtet hat wir sind heute
morgen um kurz nach fünf aufgeschreckt
weil artillerie eigentlich chance wahren
so ist die lage hier
das ist furchtbar furchtbar zu hören
wenn sie das jetzt für einen pauls
berichten wie muss denn jetzt die ampel
regierung reagieren also zunächst einmal
ist es außerordentlich wichtig dass wir
vor allem im bündnis geschlossen
auftreten
das darf man nicht unterschätzen denn
die dinge die gerade hier diskutiert
werden in europa oder den usa diskutiert
werden die wird man
in moskau sehr genau betrachten nun
analysieren wichtig ist dass wir alle
mit einer stimme sprechen und vor allem
uns nicht auseinanderdividieren lassen
nicht bei der frage wenn es um die
sanktionen geht übrigens die sanktionen
sind aus meiner sicht notwendig das ist
aber nur ein erster wichtiger schritt
denn was danach kommt ist aus meiner
sicht noch wichtiger denn in der tat ist
es so kurzfristig steht beim herrn putin
natürlich das militärische im
mittelpunkt
ob die sanktionen ihn beeindrucken
werden oder nicht
ich glaube für herrn putin ist es
inzwischen auch der so irrational das
ganze auch ist völlig irrelevant ob
jetzt ob es den menschen in russland gut
geht oder nicht so gut geht ich glaube
auf dauer werden wir eine nicht nur eine
debatte sondern wir müssen auch handeln
wir werden künftig mehr
diplomatie und sicherheit investieren
müssen das heißt wir werden künftig
nicht nur in deutschland vor allem also
auch in europa mehr in außen- und
sicherheitspolitik investieren müssen
wir müssen mehr investieren die
sicherheitspolitik und da darf ich noch
mal erinnern weil sie auch freuen ein
zitat von frau kramp karrenbauer erwähnt
haben es ist ja in der vergangenheit
eher nicht so gewesen dass wir in
deutschland groß breit waren in die
sicherheitspolitik zu investieren und
wir waren auch nie musterland wenn es
darum gegen beispielsweise auch
innerhalb der nato als organisation die
ziele der nato zu verfolgen
beispielsweise diese organisation zu
stabilisieren ich denke der heutige tag
spätestens jetzt
sollten wir darüber im klaren sein dass
eine neue zeit beginnt
eine neue zeit beginnt er einmal ist
also die alte zeit und damit auch die
alte bundesregierung mit schuld an
diesem desaster also erst einmal glaube
ich dass es wenig bringt sich rausreden
zu wollen wir alle tragen doch
verantwortung wir haben damals als die
grimm annektiert wurde als der donbass
destabilisiert wurde durch die
separatisten
gemeinsam das abkommen von minz zustande
gebracht das ist dann später nicht
umgesetzt worden darüber kann man lange
diskutieren aber es ist unter gar keinen
umständen eine rechtfertigung für
russland dieses große land mit
unschuldigen menschen anzugreifen und
seiner freiheit und her zu berauben so
und wir haben damals mit
wirtschaftssanktionen reagiert die
übrigens heute noch in kraft sind wegen
der annexion der grimm und es hat die
russische das hat die russische
wirtschaft in eine schwere krise
gestürzt 23 jahre lang ich glaube dass
wir viel tun können das signal um das
signal glaubwürdig zu untermauern dass
es sich nicht auszahlt und nicht lohnt
die alternative herr strunz über die sie
reden wäre doch wäre doch dass sie mit
militärischer gewalt in der ukraine
eingreifen und das möchte niemand das
möchte die beiden nicht das möchte die
nato nicht das möchte die eu nicht das
möchte auch kein verantwortlicher
politiker in deutschland und deshalb ist
es aus meiner sicht die einzige
möglichkeit dass wir bei diplomatische
beziehungen botschaftspersonal abberufen
ausweisen sanktionen ergreifen
in wirtschaftsbeziehungen verändern dass
wir dafür sorgen dass vladimir putin
auch im eigenen land derjenige sein wird
der die schuld daran trägt dass russland
noch einmal in die wirtschaftspolitische
entwicklungszeit zurück war jetzt haben
sie doch praktisch ein wunderbares
argument vorgetragen die sanktionen die
gegen russland schon verhängt waren nach
der grimm die also wunderbarerweise
russland so die knie gezwungen haben das
jetzt mit der größten militärmacht wie
man sich vorstellen kann nachbar
überfällt das ist doch im grunde nach
gerade die der beleg dass sanktionen
allein ein stumpfes schwert sind sie
muss hätten wir tun sollen wir haben
aber ich
sage nicht das wird umso ich sagte mir
nicht das schon nicht sagt nach vorne
und dann können wir das ich sagen da
vorne hinein was mich bewegt ja was ich
heute zum beispiel vermisst hat ist dass
die eu signalisiert alle flüchtlinge
sind in der eu will eine breaking news
klar sie haben ja gesprochen heute
unbedingt aber jedes mal das auch zu
sagen und wir haben jetzt auch paul
zugeschaltet der mit uns darüber
sprechen wird und zwar ruft der
präsident zur mobilmachung auf der
ukrainische präsident seinen ski aber
bitte paul erklärt du es lieber in
deinen worten so viel besser als ich es
hier im studio überhaupt könnte
was bedeutende habe einen übersetzer in
dem ihr einen freund auch von mir seit
vielen vielen jahren der hat gerade
geschockt auf sein handy geschaut weil
dieser meldung kam es kommt eine
generalmobilmachung 18 bis 60 jahre
männer dürfen das land nicht mehr
verlassen also diejenigen wieder darüber
nachgedacht haben hier aus der ukraine
herauszugehen vielleicht nach polen zu
flüchten oder in die eu zu flüchten die
dürfen nicht mehr raus sie werden dann
oder würden dann an der grenze
aufgehalten also gerade in die augen
meines freundes dort geschaut der sehr
verzweifelt ist darüber denn er will
nicht in die armee er steht zwar auf der
seite seines landes aber hat natürlich
große sorge davor das ja hier gegen eine
russische armee zu
teil 1 bleiben ja wirklich die worte weg
man denkt natürlich auch selber wie es
jetzt wäre wenn der eigene vater die
eigenen geschwister die lage ist hätten
wir in der ukraine was kann man denn tun
also wie wie wir dieser konflikt sich
entwickeln was wird jetzt in den
nächsten stunden und tagen passieren
es wird jetzt darauf ankommen was in
kiew passiert ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass kiew als hauptstadt
wirklich schon heute nacht komplett
fallen wird allerdings scheint es so
dass russland die gesamte lufthoheit in
der ukraine hat und natürlich auch
technologie überlegen ist vielleicht
einen anstoß in die diskussion ich
glaube was viele menschen in der ukraine
so frustriert herr altmaier ist dass man
in den vergangenen sieben jahren immer
wieder gewarnt hat man hat gewarnt seid
nicht so naiv hört guten geschäfte zu
machen sie selbst noch besucht vor ein
paar jahren als wirtschaftsminister da
gibt es fotos von ihnen und wladimir
putin zusammen und die große frage ist
warum war die deutsche politik so naiv
erstens und zweitens fragen sich viele
ukraine wie kann es sein dass putin das
land angreift 6 uhr morgens hier
luftschläge artillery moerser menschen
umkommen und am gleichen tag deutschland
wieder bremst bei den sanktionen und
sagt swift da wollen wir nicht ran und
seelands geht der präsident wieder
verzweifelt sagt wie kann das sein
wir haben ich sie wissen ja heraus damit
habe einen enormen respekt vor ihrer
leistung wie sie in krisengebieten rund
um die welt berichten und dafür sorgen
dass man es weiß in einem punkt bin ich
anderer auffassung ich glaube wenn wir
herrn putin vor acht jahren als er die
krim überfallen annektiert hat mit einem
kontakt und besuchsverbot belegt hätten
wenn wir die gespräche abgebrochen
hätten hätte ihn das von seinen aktionen
mit sicherheit nicht zurückgehalten
vielleicht hätte er sogar früher
losgeschlagen und das gemacht was er
offenbar damals schon im kopf hatte das
zweite ist ja es gibt ein versprechen
des westens dass wir wirklich harte
sanktionen verhängen ich kenne das
ergebnis der besprechungen in brüssel
heute abend noch nicht weiß auch gelebte
europäische rat schon beendet ist aber
ich werde natürlich die westlichen
führer auch daran messen und zwar alle
miteinander
ob sie dieses versprechen einlösen so
und das wird öffentlich diskutiert
werden das ist der freund einer
demokratie und dem müssen sich alle
stellen das was ich jetzt allerdings
heute abend auch für wichtig halte ist
das wir nicht hätten die situation haben
alte minister schlägt auf den neuen
minister die neuen minister ein dass wir
in england in frankreich undenkbar in so
einer krisensituation sondern wir müssen
jetzt auch mal dazu bereit sein die
amtierende regierung zu ermuntern intern
natürlich und zu unterstützen auch
öffentlich wenn sie dann auch schwierige
entscheidungen trifft das ist das was
jetzt geschehen muss und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir in den nächsten
tagen da noch sehr deutlich vorankommen
in den nächsten tagen geht es die
ukraine so wie wir sie kennen dann nicht
mehr geben herr altmaier und was olaf
scholz heute gesagt hat dass putin
diesen krieg nicht gewinnen wird oder
nicht gewinnen kann dann kann ich nur
sagen in diesen stunden gewinnt platini
putin gerade den krieg genau hier wo ich
gerade bin es wird aber egal was die
europäische union beschließt
nicht dazu führen dass irgendeine aktion
die herr putin heute nacht oder morgen
früh exekutiert
aufgehoben wird geändert wird oder nicht
stattfindet diese maschine hat er in
gang gesetzt ich habe mich immer
gewundert wie manche die amerikanische
nachrichtendienste den amerikanischen
präsidenten lächerlich gemacht haben und
gesagt haben das ist alles panikmache
ich habe das immer für eine realistische
möglichkeit gehalten dass dies geschieht
wenn man 100.000 leute zusammen zieht
das kostet ja viele millionen dann auch
um diese operation zu finanzieren hat
man damit etwas vor und das was jetzt
eingeleitet ist wird entweder durch die
tapferkeit der ukrainischen soldaten und
durch die den durchhaltewillen der
regierung aufgehalten oder aber es wird
heute nacht seinen oder morgen früh
seinen verlauf nehmen aber ich sage
ihnen die ukraine wird es auch noch in
20 30 und 40 jahren geben und was urlaub
stolz darauf sagen wollte ist diese
gewalt wird sich am ende gegen den
kehren der sie angewendet hat wenn sie
wie reden und die briefe von winston
churchill sehen als hitler damals ich
mache jetzt keinen vergleich also hitler
ist unvergleichlich mit irgendjemand
aber großbritannien war auf der
verliererstraße der krieg schien
verloren und trotzdem hat er gesagt sie
können tun was sie wollen am ende werden
wir gewinnen und das hat olaf scholz
heute auch gesagt und ich bin froh dass
er es gesagt hat denn wir dürfen nicht
kleinmütig in die nächsten tage gehen
sondern mit dem selbstbewusstsein der
freiheit und des westens
ja weil das ist eine wahnsinnige
tragödie und ich muss zugeben als ich
heute morgen aufgewacht bin hätte ich
nicht gedacht dass putin mit dieser
vehemenz
einsteigt ich gehörte auch zu denen wo
sie zugleich dass sie gesagt haben die
amerikaner betreiben der panikmache ich
hab gedacht das ist eine drohkulisse und
da habe ich mich getäuscht und ich habe
in der gestrigen sendung auch gesagt
dass es
tragische fehler gegeben hat auf beiden
seiten aber ich kann nach dem westen
hier den vorwurf nicht ersparen nichts
aber rechtfertigt aus was putin jetzt
morgen aber der entscheidende punkt ist
natürlich welche lehren ziehen wir
daraus und wenn ich eure diskussion
gehöre und das mit allem respekt und ich
bin ja von außen hier möchte ich mich
auch etwas zurückhaltender sind dann
stellen wir doch einfach fest dass der
westen im begriff ist seine aura des
schreckens auch seine autorität zu
verlieren wenn ein putin einfach
reingeht dann kalkuliert der eiskalt und
sagt ich kann mir das erlauben weil er
ist kein hasardeur das nicht irgendein
spinner und das ist natürlich eine
brutale entlarvung der schwächen des
westens und das ist auch eine quittung
und da nehme ich die schweiz und andere
länder mit ein das ist doch die quittung
für eine politik des gezielten abbaus
des militärs in den letzten 30 jahren
wir haben ja unsere eigenen immer mehr
herunter gefahren wir haben uns mehr mit
gender toiletten beschäftigt und allen
möglichen dingen klimamodellen in der
zukunft aber die elementaren
geostrategischen aspekte ab mir
ausgeblendet und jetzt merken wir dass
krieg eine fürchterliche realität ist
und deshalb plädiere ich dafür aus ich
meine was heißt plädiere ich dafür
später eigentlich keine rolle was ich
probiere ich sage einfach es ist die
dringende notwendigkeit
dass die eu dass der westen die nato die
militärischen kapazitäten wieder
hochfährt damit man in den verhandlungen
auch das nötige gewicht reinbringt meine
angst bei den auktionen ist die aber
dann konrad meier das natürlich
vielleicht besser beschreiben ich habe
einfach die befürchtung dass die
sanktionen die der westen gegen russland
ergreift möglicherweise für die
europäische union noch wohin würden zu
wenig so das büro ist aus für die ruf
wenig sagt sie und die frage würde ich
gerne einen herrn james reichstein sie
verfolgen ja immer sehr aufmerksam auch
den iran und der wurde ja von der
weltgemeinschaft isoliert können wir das
jetzt nicht einfach auch mit russland
machen also zunächst einmal um diese
frage beantworten greife ich nochmal die
frage von paul ronzheimer auch warum ist
die deutsche politik oder warum ist die
politik im westen so naiv ganz einfach
weil die politik der letzten jahre im
grunde genommen auch ein spiegelbild der
gesellschaft in deutschland war der
zustand der bundeswehr in den letzten
stunden ist viel über den zustand der
bundeswehr gesprochen worden das ist ein
spiegelbild der debatten die wir alle
zusammen in der politik in den letzten
20 bis 25 jahren geführt haben denn wir
sind in diesem land und das ist auch so
eine politik sehr stark auf unsere
probleme im land fokussiert das ist auch
in erster linie richtig so aber wir
sollten zumindest zur kenntnis nehmen
dass die welt in der wir leben sich
gerade dramatisch verändert nur bis
jetzt war es immer sehr einfach wir
konnten uns immer zurücklehnen und haben
immer irgendwie gehofft dass die
amerikaner das für uns regeln werden und
wir waren dann diejenigen die das
hinterher dann kommentiert haben um am
liebsten moralisch kommentiert haben nun
jetzt ändert sich die welt die
konflikte die es gab die werden
komplexer und übrigens die amerikaner
egal wer jetzt demnächst im weißen haus
sitzt die haben für sich grundsätzlich
jetzt die entscheidung getroffen dass
die europäer sich selbst um ihre
probleme kümmern müssen und das ist ein
großes problem ich war hier im studio da
haben wir uns die frage gestellt hier da
vorne saßen wir was sind die lehren die
wir aus dem afghanistan einsatz gestimmt
wir haben hier mal uns nur die frage
gestellt wie gehen wir mit china und was
sind die lehren die wir daraus sehen wir
sitzen jetzt hier für sie haben gerade
gefragt und was ist mit dem iran also
sind wir auch da naiv was sind die
lehren also wir sind permanent die man
in diesen fragen drin und ja und es ist
in der tat naiv und diese vorstellung
dass man einfach wirtschaftlich
zusammenarbeitet und eines tages die
dinge sich alle regeln diese vorstellung
ist nicht mehr zeitgemäß diese
vorstellung ist beim iran gescheitert
bei china gescheitert und ist übrigens
auch bei russland gescheitert darüber
muss man uns im klaren zeit haben leute
wie putin jetzt gedanken letzten letzten
viertel aller letzter gedanke leute wie
putin beeindruckt man nicht indem man
noch mehr dialog angebote macht ich bin
absolut dafür es gibt in diesem konflikt
nur eine diplomatische lösung aber damit
diplomatie überhaupt eine
glaubwürdigkeit bekommt müssen wir die
richtigen signale die richtige
sicherheitsarchitekturen
es auch einer unserer reporter vor ort
chefreporter mit politik peter wenn du
des izrs worüber wir debattieren du bist
vor ort eben hat er einmal gesagt die
ukraine weil das auch noch in 20 30
jahren geben wie erlebst du es gerade
vor ort dieser unfassbare krieg
also ich bin ja auf der russischen seite
der frontlinie komischerweise ist dass
sie sichere seite obwohl ich auf
feindesland bin ich habe das heute auch
wieder erfahren wir waren acht stunden
lang jetzt in verhören beim fsb also bei
dem geheimdienst gleichzeitig der
grenzschutz ist und danach noch bei der
polizei und mir geht gelinde gesagt die
hutschnur gerade auseinander wenn ich an
altmaier höre wenn die roger köppel
höhere
roger köppel wir kennen uns ja ein
bisschen aber sie haben vor kurzem doch
wladimir putin verteidigt wenn sie haben
den den westen mitverantwortlich gemacht
für die eskalation
hier vor ort als rechter nationalrat aus
der schweiz würde ich da einfach mal
drei pegel runtergehen ich bin wirklich
wirklich angefasst und ich bin sauber
ich bin auch sauer auf peter altmaier
ich bin sauer auf wirklich auf unsere
politische klasse was man in den letzten
15 jahren und vor allem in den letzten
acht jahren alles falsch gemacht hat was
man wie falsch man gelegen hat wie man
mit wladimir putin umgegangen ist wie
man auf gas gesetzt hat wie man unser
land zugunsten des kremls und wir
wussten alle was wir finanzieren mit dem
gas mit unserer abhängigkeit mit mit öl
wie man die energiewende so auf
russisches gas und öl vor allem auf
russisches gas bauen konnte und auf den
traum dass wir eines tages wasserstoff
aus russland kriegen und gleichzeitig
wussten wir dass wir die kriegskasse von
wladimir putin fühlen und alle die davor
gewarnt haben was kommen kann sind immer
abgetan worden als homophob als alles
mögliche oder als sonst was und wir
stehen jetzt schlicht und ergreifend wir
deutschen stehen vor dem trümmerhaufen
unserer außenpolitik der letzten jahre
von dem trümmerhaufen unserer
wirtschaftspolitik und den preis zahlen
gerade die ukraine paul ist da paul
kennt das land ich habe die ukraine auch
viel bereist carson da wo ich mal weiß
ich noch da war ich vor wenigen jahren
mit mit unserem fotografen christian
christian knieps da waren wir touristen
die haben wir wurden für touristen
hatten sie sind so freundlich begrüßt
war wir haben da frisches bier getrunken
und diese stadt ist heute gefallen mario
pohl ist kurz davor zurück zu fallen
diese stadt ich habe vor wenigen wochen
noch freunden empfohlen wenn ihr mal den
ostblock wollt wenn ihr in die ehemalige
sowjetunion und wollten ihr wollt ein
bisschen freiheit genießen und eine
stadt hat dient ein anderes klima hat
als moskau zum zum beispiel da fliegt
doch mal nach hier fliegt einfach mal in
die ukraine guckt euch an die ganz
sympathische stadt relativ jungen
relativ offen klar ist die ukraine ein
schwieriges land aber wirklich mir geht
die hutschnur und ich könnte würde ich
heulen und ich könnte schreien wenn ich
sehe was da passiert nicht wenn ich
diese auswahl aus der bundespolitik
kennen sich doch viel besser aus als sie
jetzt wissen wir haben 2009 10 in meinem
ministerium hier in berlin mit der
ukraine auf wunsch der ukraine gegenüber
russland durchgesetzt dass die nächsten
fünf jahre gas durch die ukraine
geliefert wird es war der wunsch der
ukraine die nase aus fünf jahre her als
fünf jahre ich davon 15 jahre zahlen
nichts haben und im übrigen ich
persönlich jahre ist nicht man soll ja
niemals seine halbmayr ich kann es
wirklich nicht mehr hören ich kann das
nicht mehr hören diese fünf jahre davon
sind jetzt noch zwei oder drei jahre
übrig die die ganze strafen die ganzen
kartellstrafe die damit festgelegt waren
die russland zahlen müsste wenn sie
nicht gasdruck durchleiten die die rot
sich wladimir putin aus der hintersten
ecke seiner nase das ist portokasse das
ist für gazprom oder für andere ist dass
die portokasse fünf jahre für die
ukraine aber wir haben unsere zukunft
darauf gesetzt erzählen sie doch mal
auch dem häuslebauer und den leuten die
auf kante genäht haben
beide familien teile pendeln der eine
nach links der andere nach rechts das
haus ist auf kante gebaut alles ist
durchgerechnet die energiepreise
explosion können sie jetzt schon kaum
noch zahlen ja wieder fürs heizen noch
fürs autofahren jetzt kommt diese krise
drauf und ich kann und entschuldigen sie
wenn nicht da emotional wäre bin ja aber
ich kann als indiz mehr hören bin ja
nicht ich bin ja nicht der amtierende
bundeskanzler außenminister
finanzminister wirtschaftsminister in
personalunion ich trage meine
verantwortung für meine regierungszeit
in unterschiedlichen ministerien aber es
ist nun einmal so dass gas auf der
ganzen welt teurer geworden ist nicht
nur in russland es ist teuer und wir
haben aufgehört haben die haben
eigentlich gerade geraten überall halten
wir schalten atomkraftwerke
abschalten atomkraftwerke ab und für
garcia russischen sie da entscheidet
auch die atomkraftwerke einfach wieder
eine zeitung geschrieben hat bei
fukushima wie schlimmer und wie
schrecklich das ist die wochenlang 23
seiten jeden tag und es gab eine
mehrheit von 80 prozent in der
bevölkerung aus der nutzung der
atomenergie auszusteigen
das hat der bundestag beschlossen mit
einer dreiviertelmehrheit so und nun
sagen sie und daran haben uns alle gut
dann haben wir den anderen themen ich
finde das ist nicht okay ich finde man
muss mit diesen dingen bei harald meyer
gehen sat 1 hat ein vom alter her dann
haben uns für alle geräte dann haben wir
uns in münchen die frage gestellt wer
ist denn bereit ein neues atomkraftwerk
in seiner stadt oder ein endlager in
seiner stadt zu übernehmen wo kann einst
gebaut werden ja wenn wir das machen
wollen und wir können darüber sehr viel
diskutieren in der zwischenzeit
schreiten die schaden von herrn putin
vor angemessen und unterdrücken die
freiheit in der ukraine wir wollen ja
auch gleich nach zu philippi abschalten
aber einer möchte ich gerne rosa teppich
war wieder auf zu anfang ihr glaube ich
angesprochen wurden von peter tiede und
ich konnte es nicht verstehen wenn du da
in dieser situation bist dann bist du
aufgewühlt aber wir müssen schon
aufpassen dass man da nicht am abgrund
und ich glaube der entscheidende punkt
ist dass es ist richtig ich mache dem
westen große vorwürfe im umgang mit
russland da bin ich aber nicht alleine
ich habe gestern zitiert george f kennen
einer der bedeutendsten nicht heute
nicht sagen schnell eine eine dass wir
bei den fakten bleiben dass der westen
schwere fehler gemacht hat das
rechtfertigt in keiner art und weise und
verteidigt auch nicht irgendein
verhalten dass putin auch dass er die
volle verantwortung trägt aber wir
müssen uns schon vor augen führen das
namhafteste us senatoren in den 90er
jahren den amerikanischen präsidenten
clinton gewarnt haben vor einer allzu
forschen nach durst erweiterung und wenn
wir diesen konflikt verstehen worden vor
allem wenn wir ihn lösen wollen da
müssen wir schon auch versuchen zu
begreifen wie wir in diese position
gekommen sind weil sonst verflacht die
analyse und dann haben wir auch keine
vernünftigen lösungen um aus das
bedauerlich ist also glaubt die tebus
einmal an worden und jetzt einmal noch
antwort und können dann können wir gerne
aufsuchen also ich halt nicht so dass
der westen diese länder gezwungen eben
nicht untergehen sondern diese menschen
haben ein bedürfnis nach sicherheit
gehabt und warum ist das so weil die
sich bedroht
und wenn man sich russland bedroht fühlt
dann sucht man bündnis lustig und
übrigens das ist auch hier in dem fall
so nicht nicht nicht die
nicht russland wird bedroht von der
ukraine sondern die ukraine von russland
reagiert und deswegen ist das eine
legende das ist nur ich will dass nur
sagen dass ich meine das überhaupt nicht
ist ja nicht gegen sie gerichtet wir
sollten nun diese legende wichtig finde
erweiterungen überzogen hergang russland
provoziert hat das ist eine legende
sondern es ist diese menschen die
menschen die in diesen ländern leben
wollten freiheit und wollten dass
sicherheit und deswegen haben die sich
bewusst für unsere werte für unser
system entschieden und bewusst gegen
dieses system habe ich
die entscheidung der menschen in diesen
ländern ist aber ja richtig was sie
sagen ich zitiere hier ja in dieser
sendung aussagen von amerikanischen
senatoren das sage nicht ich zitiere das
dhm einmal ganz kurz und dich fertig er
nur einmal antwort finde ich man kann
nicht einfach jemanden zitieren sich
darauf berufen und und dann sagen das
sage nicht ich doch rosa klappe das
sagen sie und man kann doch nicht sagen
wo ist denn die diesen wo ist die
forscher da die ost erweiterung
wer grenzt denn bitteschön annan an
russland das sind estland und litauen
und lettland und ganz oben im norden
glaube ich noch ein bisschen finnland
oder norwegen
das war es dann mit der großen
umzingelung es gibt die angesprochenen
nato osterweiterung nicht und ein us
präsident hat nicht entschieden über
einen nato osterweiterung das sind die
länder die eintreten wollten und die
sind in der regel weggelaufen von moskau
und das ist der grund warum sie in einer
doch noch weil ich da direkt
angesprochen bin ich glaube einfach um
die situation auch für die zukunft und
eine lösung zu finden richtig zu
analysieren müssen wir zur kenntnis
nehmen dass russland das größte land
dieser welt ist flächenmäßig und wenn
wir eine sicherheitsarchitektur und wenn
die eu eine sicherheitsarchitektur
aufbaut dann muss sie auch die
sicherheitsinteressen der russen
berücksichtigen da kann man schon sagen
das sind alles purer neugier und die
ähren sich und das sind alles verbrecher
habe ich keinen sicherheit und die
fehlende ruhig will er wohl gegen oder
jahren argumente sind getauscht und so
weiter nicht ich glaube wenn du uns
jetzt hat man in der ukraine zu hören
würde oder jemand in deutschland zu
hören der ferne in der ukraine hat sich
und denken jetzt erst mal genug mit
chemie ja wir wollen jetzt eigentlich
wissen wir uns hilft ja sowie helft wir
uns der hand ich fand ein argument ganz
interessant weil das ja nur
demokratisches argumente die menschen in
den ländern hatten ein
sicherheitsbedürfnis und haben sich
deshalb sozusagen von russland abgewandt
und dem westen zugewandt das gleiche
gilt auch für die ukraine nur halt ohne
der nato beigetreten zu sein und die
frage die daraus resultiert ist ja auf
welchen schutz kann sich die ukraine
jetzt eigentlich verlassen und die
menschen dort aus dem westen und wir
sind von unterbrochen waren an einer
stelle an der sie mich geglaubt haben
gestellt zu haben weil ich sozusagen
keine vorschläge habe was weiß ich nicht
was mich heute bewegt ist es gibt ein
paar dinge die man machen kann noch
bevor man die waffen zeigt ja man kann
humanitäre hilfe leisten ja welche er
dafür habe ich aber alles nichts
jedoch kann habe ich heute hat man
bekannt ist gesagt die leute werden in
nordrhein westfalen aufgenommen es haben
kritiker aller parteien das gesagt ich
wiederhole dass auch hier ich war
flüchtlings koordinator als wir menschen
geholfen haben die in syrien in
lebensgefahr waren und ich bin sicher
dass deutschland sich vor dieser
verantwortung und wirke sind es war so
dass ich habe ja sichere ein draw ist
denn wohl ihre plan den wir sichern für
flüchtlinge wir müssen diesen menschen
helfen die erhärten die werden aber
konkret die werden nach polen gehen die
werden lange slowakei gehen die werden
dorthin gehen wo sie grenzen zur
europäischen union haben und wir müssen
bereit sein ihnen zu helfen nicht mehr
da ich mir ich würde mir auch wünschen
dass sie ihr dass wir den
intellektuellen den den demokraten die
dort den demokratischen widerstand
organisieren dass wir auch denen eine
möglichkeit bieten diesem tyrannen zu
entkommen und ich würde mir auch
wünschen
die stoffe lieber kollege dass es
gemacht und vielleicht geben sie dem
gesundheitsminister anderen hinweis wir
müssen uns auch darauf vorbereiten
medizinische hilfe zu leisten es werden
raketenangriffe zu fahren ist werden
flugzeuge eingesetzt wird geschossen und
die ukraine wird sehr schnell an die
grenzen ihrer medizinischen
leistungsfähigkeit kommen auch dort
müssen wir helfen müssen wir auch
patienten aufnehmen denen dort nicht
geholfen werden kann das halte ich für
das mindeste da bin ich ausdrücklich bei
ihnen wir müssen und wir werden helfen
aber trotzdem der punkt ist berechtigt
für diejenigen die in der ukraine leben
und unseren debatten hier zu hören kommt
jede hilfe zu spät ja und das war doch
ein gast heute politischen realität und
das ist dann der abend einmal sagen und
ich sage dazu vielleicht konnten wir
nicht anders obwohl ich das so auch für
schwächlich halte wir haben die menschen
in der ukraine im stich gelassen das ist
das was geschehen ist denn sie sind
jetzt umzingelt von einem aggressor der
sich eine stadt nach der andern nimmt
jetzt vor der hauptstadt steht und das
sind sie jetzt und wir sind hier und wir
flügeln rum und die haben bald nichts
mehr zu essen weil nämlich die
supermärkte jetzt schon alle leer sind
und es gibt auch keinen sprit und ich
finde es ist zu wenig die solidarität
immer zu bekunden aber dann wenn sie
gefordert ist sich in akademische zirkel
zurückziehen und sanktionen für in drei
monaten beschließen das finde ich nicht
und jetzt komme ich zu meinem punkt um
den wir doch eigentlich rum
wenn ein königspudel einem kampfhund
begegnet dann hilft dem königspudel
seine ganze klugheit nicht am schluss
weist der kampfhund zu und das ist das
was geschieht und das muss man
aussprechen wenn der königspudel nicht
dreikampf und freunde mitbringt und sagt
was man aufdruck kampf und jetzt sind
wir die mehreren die stärkeren dann hat
er keine chance da kann er noch so oft
das kleine einmaleins untersagen der
königspudel das kann er noch so oft
mache es wird ihm nicht helfen was hilft
ist jetzt und ich habe es vorhin schon
mal es gibt ja ein begriff es hilft
jetzt auch und es muss schnell geschehen
und auch die nato hat eine sitzung für
morgen angekündigt immerhin würde ich
sagen noch schneller als der deutsche
bundestag
wir müssen jetzt auch die waffen zeigen
wir müssen an dieser ostgrenze der nato
auch aufmarschieren mir ist schon klar
dass man da jetzt keine soldaten
hinschicken wir müssen zeigen dass wenn
der gute mann du den ist esse ich auch
nur einen funken gedanken darüber macht
soldaten über die politische kompass und
also länger
als verteidigungsminister in dafür
gesorgt dass wir in litauen als nato
präsent geworden sind als bundeswehr
präsent geworden annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat es verstärkt die
amerikaner werden es verstärken das
werden wir alle tun wenn jemand niki der
nato ist und wir haben die nato
erweitert in der regierungszeit übrigens
in der ich auch mit dieser regierung
angehört habe wir haben sie erweitert um
estland lettland litauen und polen aber
ich habe auch die ganze rechnen er
starte ich will eine andere frau die
haben die volle beistandsgarantie es
fertig man hat eben einen unterschied
und das muss man das hat joe biden
gesagt dass olaf scholz gesagt es macht
einen unterschied ob du in der nato
mitglied bist und die artikel von spd
oder ob sie deutlich mehr geht es um mir
geht es um etwas anderes mir geht's
jetzt ja schon um das nato gebiet oder
einen möglichen bündnis weil ich glaube
dass wir viel deutlicher machen müssen
wir haben mehr panzer wir haben mehr
flieger wir haben mehr soldaten wir sind
besser ausgerüstet und herr putin wenn
sie es dieses gebiet zu betreten dann
setzen wird das auch ein wir führen dann
auch einen krieg und das ist doch der
das ist doch dass und dass wir alle
umschleichen das wohl eines tages
vielleicht einer phase wo ich mich
erklären macht vielleicht mehr putin hat
ja auch schon mit möglichen ist er von
dem raum aber er verstehe ich und da
kann man jetzt auch nicht auf jede aber
wenn es passiert müssen wir uns doch
klar sein und wir müssen es auch mal
aussprechen dann müssen wir es auch tun
und einlösen und ich habe das gefühl ich
sagen dass ich nicht gefehlt aber dann
gelang mir passieren dann wieder ob das
jetzt schon ausreicht ob das jetzt
reicht und so weiter und wir werden
unsere eigene stoßkraft durch debatten
schwächen oder das wird dieser mann aus
kulturen senders darauf abgesehen hatte
seit dem bestehen der nato das sind
jetzt an die 70 jahre keinen einzigen
fall wo ein nato-mitglied im stich
gelassen wurde wenn es von einem
ausländischen aggressor überfallen wird
und es wird da bin ich ganz sicher da
werden cdu csu spd fdp grüne zusammen
stehen auch in zukunft nicht geschehen
aber es gab auch nur ein so mächtiges
angreifer fahrlässig daran zweifel zu
wecken wir haben das immer eingelöst und
wir werden das einlösen und als die
amerikaner in afghanistan oder von von
der damals von dem von al qaida
angegriffen wurden haben wir den artikel
5 aktiviert wir sind nach afghanistan
gegangen wir sind 20 jahre dort
geblieben wir haben alles getan am ende
am ende gab es eine unrühmliche
erreichung wir haben ja die haben ja
auch mir persönlich für probleme
abgehalten habe und so ist es ja um noch
mal wir haben ja die sendung angefangen
mit dem zitat von frau kam kam und
kinder und gucke aus dass auch normal
und es ist ja in der tat so angefangen
erinnert sich auch noch
lesen weil das so schön er ja frau kramp
karrenbauer hat getwittert ich bin so
wütend auf uns weil wir historisch
versagt haben wir haben nach geräumigen
kim und donbass nichts vorbereitet
nichts vorbereitet haben was ihn
wirklich abgeschlossen und jetzt nochmal
zurück die 2008 georgien der georgien
feldzugs
verlief im prinzip nach demselben
drehbuch wie die operation die wii jetzt
gerade beobachten übrigens das ganze
auch mit den aus rennt ausrede mit den
lügen die ganzen geschichten
aus meiner sicht kaum reaktionen damals
gezeigt grimm 2014
kaum reaktionen gezeigt dass putin hat
hier immer getestet wie weit kann ich
gehen und wie werden die reaktionen
seien und der hat da gesehen es gibt es
gab kaum reaktionen der bass und das
heißt er hat immer weiter und weiter
seine quasi
es seinen weg gegangen und hat gesehen
im grunde genommen hatte westen mir
nichts anderes entgegenzusetzen außer
debatten oder dieses permanente
diplomatie so und deswegen ist es aus
meiner sicht wir hätten schon nach
georgien um das einfach mal auch
selbstkritisch so sagen wir alle also
ich meine jetzt nicht keine bestimmte
koalition oder keine partei wir alle
hätten da schon die richtigen
schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen müssen
und vor allem uns auch darüber im klaren
sein müssen wohin die reise von herrn
platini putin gehen wird und das ist
wahnsinnig gefährlich ich war ich muss
sagen als ich die rede vor zwei tagen
gesehen habe also das ist ja also man
kriegt ja also das ist ja schockierend
allein wenn man sieht in was für einer
welt
parallelwelt dieser man gedanklich und
unterwegs ist das ist gefährlich und
darauf müssen wir vorbereitet sein und
darauf muss man vorbereitet sein und das
ist das was ich ganz am anfang gesagt
habe und das bedeutet mehr investieren
in die sicherheitspolitik zustand der
bundeswehr jetzt helfen bringen uns auch
die debatten nicht jetzt müssen konkrete
schritte von aktuell nicht nur kiew wo
die menschen angst haben vor der
invasion sondern auch der ort wo unser
meinung chef von bild viele page oft
gerade ist philipp wie ist die lage vor
ort du kannst viel besser in worte
fassen als ich wenn ich jetzt die frage
stellen würde
ja ich muss mich zunächst entschuldigen
für die schlechte beleuchtung aber im
griff ist seit einigen stunden
abgedunkelt die bevölkerung wurde darum
gebeten dass nicht überall auszuschalten
die stadt rottweil das nicht gelöscht
das ist eine präventive
sicherheitsmaßnahmen aus sorge vor
russischen luftangriffen und ich glaube
das trifft auch ziemlich genau die
stimmung in dieser stadt
ich glaube auch die stimmung im ganzen
land
[Musik]
start verlief so fühlt sich die ukraine
die ukraine wie wir sie bis vor kurzem
kannten sie existiert nicht mehr und sie
wird auch nicht mehr so existieren auf
die nächsten jahrzehnte hin ich glaube
das zu glauben bis dahin die menschen
verstehen nicht warum sie so alleine
gelassen werden die menschen verstehen
auch nicht warum bundeskanzler olaf
scholz sich dagegen ausgesprochen hat
russland vom 12 zahlungssystem
abzukoppeln
russland ist heute nacht einmarschiert
und das land werden luftangriffe
geflogen es werden zivile gebäude
gebäude bombardiert das sind offenbar
über 90 tausend russische soldaten in
dem keiner eingefallen mit dem ziel
diesen stark aufzulösen mit dem ziel
eine neue regierung zu installieren und
es werden hunderttausende menschen
vertrieben und in deutschland wird dazu
geschaut das wird jetzt wird immer noch
nicht gehandelt härteste sanktionen
werden nicht erhoben darüber wird nur
gesprochen ich glaube das ist die
stimmung gerade meint
philipp du selber bist ja auch du
sprichst ja selber auch russisch das
heißt es liegt ihr dort vor ort
natürlich auch alles sehr am herzen und
du hast ja auch gesagt heute schaltung
mich sehr bewegt hat als ich dazu gehört
habt das ist hier schwierig gefallen ist
das erste meiner ukraine russisch zu
sprechen was könnte deutschland denn
jetzt sofort als zeichen machen neben
den sanktionen um den menschen vor ort
vielleicht hoffnung zu geben
also ich komme aus einer ukrainisch
russischen familie und ich war schon
mehrfach in dem keine und hat mich
eigentlich immer wohl gefühlt auch wenn
putin immer verbreiten lässt dass das
land trotz of hope und geradezu
nationalsozialistisch ist das ist alles
frei erfunden dass das gelogen sonst
würde ein ägyptische präsident lenski
dort gar nicht regieren
ich glaube was deutschland tun muss ist
auf jeden fall so selbstverständlich
sind sein ganzer sanktionen ergeben ich
meine deutschland rühmt sich doch so
sehr aus seiner geschichte gelernt zu
haben und heute spätestens hat sich
rausgestellt dass man oder gar nichts
gelernt hat oder exakt das falsche denn
wir haben den einen gefährlichen
diktator der europa jetzt wird nicht
bedrohlich wird dann haben wir
aufsteigen lassen und wir haben ihnen
bei diesem aufsteig aufstieg unterstützt
und finanziert unser altkanzler der auch
von teilnehmer dieser runde immer wieder
verteidigt wurde ist sein wichtigster
lobby ist ein enger vertrauter unseres
altkanzlers gerhard schröder ist aktuell
unser staatsoberhaupt der mann der
architekt der deutschen außenpolitik der
minsk mitverhandelt hat die minsk
verträge zwischen der ukraine und den
sogenannten prorussischen separatisten
das alles ist es der ukraine deutschland
europa und der welt jetzt wirklich auf
die füße gefallen und ich glaube ich
hoffe dass dieser schock über den
angriff nicht nur 24 oder 48 oder 72
stunden hält sondern wirklich nachhaltig
wirkt ansonsten den lieben wenig
wirklich nur den beginn einer eskalation
vielen dank für deine arbeit philipp und
dass die zeit genommen als bei der
session 1 uhr nachts müsst ihr eine
stunde später als wir hier dann habt
eine gute nacht bis es auch wieder
losgeht mit der berichterstattung wenn
überhaupt schlafen kannst das stelle ich
mir sehr schwierig vor schönen abend
noch danke dir
was wir jetzt erfahren haben den letzten
minuten das genial mobilmachung eher
dunkel um menschen sitzen irgendwie in
kellern es fliegen womöglich fliegern
acht angriffe und das alles zweieinhalb
drei flugstunden von ihr entfernt das
ist schon
wir sitzen heute schon in einem anderen
studio in einem anderen in einer anderen
umgebung als gestern und vorgestern
richtig und die frage was wir selber
dazu beigetragen haben und ob es hätte
verhindert werden können ist quälend
ende ja natürlich sie quälen ich kann
mich erinnern ich war damals schon im
bundestag der kollege wahrscheinlich
noch nicht
wladimir putin hat vor dem deutschen
bundestag eine rede gehalten und es ist
weder die spd noch die cdu und fdp noch
die grünen sind aufgestanden und sind
rausgegangen so weit ich mich erinnern
kann vielleicht ist der eine oder andere
nicht gekommen das war ein anderer das
war ein antraten das war ein anderer wer
hat und der hat erst dann im laufe der
zeit verändert und zwar zu seinem
nachteil er ist innenpolitisch
reaktionär geworden hat die opposition
unterdrückt und er ist außenpolitisch
aggressiv geworden gegen die ukraine mit
allem was wir in den letzten jahren
erlebt haben im übrigen was man auch
erwähnen muss ist syrien so und auch
dort hat er für millionenfaches leid die
verantwortung wo menschen so pflichtet
sind wir haben einen teil davon bei uns
aufgenommen das war eine sehr sehr
schwere sache aber sie war das ist meine
feste überzeugung auch richtig auch
heute noch und deshalb müssen wir
natürlich auch unsere antwort immer
wieder anpassen und ich würde nur darauf
hinweisen
dass jetzt in der situation natürlich
die härtesten sanktionen richtig ist
dann bin ich ganz bei herrn
pfs ich kann mir nicht viel schlimmeres
mehr vorstellen also wenn das wahr wird
was ich heute den tag über abgezeichnet
hat dass er tatsächlich als kriegsziel
hat die komplette eroberung der ukraine
dann ist das der schlimmste anzunehmende
fall und dann müssen wir alle sanktionen
zu denen wir theoretisch bereit sind
auch bereit sein in der praxis
umzusetzen
und ich glaube es gibt zwei wesentliche
befunde das eine hat der filipiak gesagt
das ganze ist natürlich ein schock und
ich hoffe dass das ein
realitätsschock ist also was den westen
auf weg damit das möglich ist was du
vorhin gesagt dass klar ist ich meine
das ist der entscheidende punkt wir
haben ja noch über etwas gar nicht
gesprochen wir reden über die ukraine
aber putin steht ja bereits in
weißrussland da hat er auch sehr viele
truppen und die idee dass er da wieder
raus geht ist ja abwegig und das heißt
weißrussland ist und sehr nahe am
baltikum die großen russischen
minderheit das ist bereits eine
diskussion und da wird dann ganz
entscheidend sein mit dem essen konto
mit dem up mit dem essen kommt der
appetit wenn putin zum schluss kommt
dass der westen nicht bereit ist dass
die nato nicht wirklich verteidigungs
bereit ist ja dann da machte das mit
seiner eiskalten strategie und was mich
einfach hier befindet ich weiß das hört
man in dieser runde nicht so gern wenn
man nicht gerne hört dass man den westen
kritisiert aber ich finde es
erschütternd den mangel an strategie und
zwar nicht erst hat heute sondern schon
seit gestern und wir sind doch einfach
tschuldigung ein bisschen wohlstands
verwahrlost geworden im westen wir haben
die verteidigung vernachlässigt wir
haben die sicherheit vernachlässigt und
stellen wir uns jetzt mal vor was
passiert nicht nur hier in europa in
afrika in asien
da schaute die ganze welt zu und zur
diskussion steht ja die box amerikaner
aber wenn wir so wie die amerikanisch
die weltordnung wo die leute vielleicht
angst bestimmte regime aber angst sich
da es dem eck aus der ecke zu wagen und
wenn die sehen dass da einfach nichts
passiert dann wird eine ganze welt
worten könnte im schlimmsten fall
destabilisiert werden also deshalb
glaube ich glaube ich bin zuversichtlich
bin noch nicht ganz so hart mit der
deutschen regierung ich finde das ist
wirklich keine einfache entscheidung
eine volle konfrontation mit russland zu
gehen das braucht sehr viel überwindung
und das sind also schwierige
entscheidungen die man dort treffen muss
aber ich glaube das wichtigste wo wir
uns sogar einig sind an diesem tisch ist
dass die rüstung die ganze militärische
dimension wieder an die spitze der
agenda kommen muss im westen in der
europäischen union deren bedarf es halt
mit diesem anlass einer totalen ehrlich
machen ich meine wir bezahlen ja nicht
mal ordentlich unseren beitrag zur nato
man richtig wir haben sogar viel
schwerer hat in den letzten jahren viel
schlimmer x3
sagen ja viel schlimmer wir haben uns
sogar in der vergangenheit in der tat
theoretische debatten geleistet jenseits
der realität ich darf erinnern was
beispielsweise der französische
präsident der jetzt als großer
vermittler unterwegs ist was der
französische präsident vor zwei jahren
anderthalb jahren über die nato als
organisation gesagt hat er hat die nato
als im tod bezahlt aufgelöst sollten sie
übrigens über die deutsche rolle in der
vergangenheit es gab ja auch immer
wieder unmut ob deutschland sich
tatsächlich auch so verhält wie man das
auch von deutschland in so einer
organisation erwartet auch diese debatte
die ist ja immer wieder in deutschland
geführt worden das heißt es ist
offensichtlich in der vergangenheit
nicht sonderlich ernst genommen worden
welche bedeutung die nato als
organisation für uns sicher als
architektur hat ich glaube dass wir ich
denke mal dass da in der tat jetzt ein
aufwachen geben wird und dass man diese
dinge jetzt andere solchen deckel vorher
wir haben uns ja verpflichtet damals
gegenüber hannover noch zwei prozent bis
zum jahre 2022 für verteidigung
auszugeben in deutschland gibt weniger
aus als andere ich habe damals als ich
dann das cdu csu wahlprogramm schreiben
durfte auf vorschlag von frau merkel und
herrn seehofer habe ich das programm mit
ihrer billigung hineingeschrieben ja es
war in der großen koalition dann nicht
gegen den koalitionspartner spd
durchsetzbar ich habe auch wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe jetzt
festgestellt noch vor dem russischen
einmarsch dass die neue koalition sich
offenbar von dem ziel wieder wesentlich
entfernt wir haben uns ein bisschen
rango rob jetzt sowie die planungen
waren geht das wieder zurück und deshalb
bin ich den kollegen nur unterstützen
vielleicht wachen jetzt ja auch einige
auf und vielleicht können sie das noch
mal korrigieren verluste halt eben den
mut haben es gab jedes jahr zehn jahren
jahr zulegen über das was durch
inflation sowie so ausgeglichen werden
muss nur dann wird man dieses ziel in
absehbarer zeit erreichen ich habe ja
vorhin den französischen präsidenten
kritisiert aber es gab ja eine phase da
hat er alle drei tage ja sie erinnern
sich alle drei tage eine historische
rede gehalten und da hat er tatsächlich
deutschland damals ja auch ein angebot
gemacht mit der sogenannten europäische
intervention initiative aber die
damalige verteidigungsminister in kramp
karrenbauer hat darauf nicht reagieren
die damalige bundeskanzlerin hat nicht
darauf reagierten es bestand ja die
mögliche
wie sie
war so in der koalition mit mit einem
koalitionspartner mit dem sicher so
sanieren dass deshalb wünsche ich ihnen
viel erfolg könnten ja alle dass jetzt
annehmen
großen dank an unsere reporter philipp
potthoff peter tiede und paul ronzheimer
und
es geht jetzt weiter mit den news
[Musik]